well taylor lorenz works at the new york
times defending the interest of the
ruling class by force she defames people
one person is fighting back however her
name is aradna jacob she's recently
filed the 6 million defamation suit
against taylor lorenz ariadna jacob is
an entrepreneur and influencer marketing
expert founder of influences.com she
joins us to explain her lawsuit thanks
so much for joining us tonight we
appreciate it so taylor lorenz stalks
the landscape hurting people and if you
say something about it she claims you're
attacking her because she's got all
kinds of neuroses or whatever you're the
aggressor you're the only person i've
seen fight back tell us why you're doing
this and what your claim against her is
thanks tucker
uh well to give you some background i
dedicated my career to the influencer
marketing industry for almost 20 years
before influencer was even a term and my
company influences.com was disrupting
the entertainment space
as we discovered and developed some of
the biggest internet stars in the world
including charlie demilio and addison
ray
and it was devastating when taylor
lorenz came along with the megaphone of
the new york times and decided to write
a scathing article full of lies about us
and she had to know it was lies because
we answered all her questions factually
before she published the story i lost my
business my personal reputation and my
income
in spanish we say legends but justicia
there's laws but no justice and in this
case tucker i really pray for justice
because taylor lorenz has a pattern of
lying and destroying innocent people and
manipulating young people and she needs
to be held accountable i came to this
country legally from mexico when i was a
little girl and my father died and it
was my dream to build a company and for
a privileged bully like taylor lorenz to
take it away from somebody like me is
just wrong
yeah but very common you you know her mo
though even using her name in public
will elicit some self-pitying stream on
twitter about how you're committing
violence against her and endangering her
she can totally crush your life for the
lives of kids which she has done
but you're not allowed to fight back are
you are you ready for the the further
attacks on you
well
i am i am ready but i i honestly i'm
here because i'm telling the truth and
and
i don't care what attacks come from her
in fact taylor lorenz had a conflict of
interest when she came after me she had
a financial partnership with
hollywood giants united talent agency
and uta were also my direct business
rivals um
taylor wrote a glowing article about uta
in the new york times without disclosing
that they represented her and soon after
it was announced that uta got taylor
lorenz a book deal it's no surprise that
when taylor's article left me
blacklisted and penniless that many of
my clients ended up at uta and there's
no recourse for someone like me a
non-celebrity to get the truth out there
in fact many primetime news anchors are
represented also by uta um and so but
that's not all eight months after uh her
defamatory article she continued to
attack me when she heard that i was
raising capital for a new venture she
went behind the scenes calling prominent
people in the media ranting that i'm a
literal abuser who doesn't deserve
positive press i guess to [ __ ] my
career and silence me forever um and
this is an abusive power
the new york times even after i filed a
lawsuit against them which isn't easy by
the way they continue to stand behind
taylor's disgusting and sinister
behavior how does taylor lorenz still
have a job
because she's intimidated people into
silence she's the bully but she's
calling you an abuser
i hope you end this i i really do
ariadne jacob thank you thank you so
much all of us who've watched this with
jaws open how is this woman terrorizing
the country and nobody has the stones to
fight back so thanks hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else